One of my least popular ideas was for a completely germfree hot dog stand.
At outdoor food carts, it's easy for germs to transfer from money to your food.
So to completely eliminate this,...
...I designed a hands-free method to apply condiments to the wiener.
Also, there would be a second employee whose only job is to handle the money.
What are you doing with the wallet?
We're doing a germfree experience so you don't handle your own money.
Oh, really?
But people were a bit annoyed with the money handling part.
Can I have my wallet back?
And the hands-free onion dispenser proved to be problematic as well.
So you have to up, one up, one down.
When it hits the table, the onions will fall.
Now drop it, keep dropping it.
Up and down, drop it fast.
This is not gonna work.
That's nothing to do with the contraption.
If you drop a hot dog, you drop a hot dog.
The public just wasn't ready for the germfree hot dog experience,...
...so I laid the concept to rest.